[Music]  today the king of pops daughter Paris  celebrates her 20th birthday  well she once she was shielded by the  spotlight but today Paris is now growing  up right before our eyes  Michael's only daughter was just nine  years old when she lost her dad and  seemed to struggle a bit in her teen  years something mom Debbie wrote shared  with us back in 2013 she's not out of  line she's not out of line she's hurting  here's my attitude Michael told me that  one when she was 2 he said she's  hard-headed she's exactly like you but  according to her source Paris is quote  in a really good place in her life and  career now and remains focused on acting  and on her activism even landing a role  in Charlize Theron's movie gringo so are  you in Paris was rumored to be dating  actress Cara Delevingne after photos  recently emerged of the two locked in a  kiss but each he has learned quote  they're just friends  [Music]